c'était l'info média de cette semaine
jarry qui officiait depuis quelques
années sur tf1 désormais en contrat avec
france 2 génial bravo si la nouvelle a
fait l'effet d'une bombe jarry s'est
expliqué dans le parisien sur ce départ
inopiné
je n'étais pas en exclusivité avec tf1
pendant un an je ne suis retrouvé sans
rien sans la scène à côté j'avais zéro
revenus une période difficile qu'il a dû
traverser durant la crise sanitaire
période où il n'avait plus aucun projet
avec la chaîne j'aurais pu aller chanter
des chansons sur le trottoir aujourd'hui
france 2 me propose un contrat je trouve
ça rassurant si l'humoriste s'était vu
confier des groupes prime comme à singer
ou encore good things heures sur tf1 il
a préféré jouer la carte de la sécurité
alors comme jarry avez vous peur de vous
retrouver sans rien du jour au lendemain
je peux répondre pour voir
non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des ongles
vraiment germain castano je crois que c
était une 9e place et est ce que cette
phrase je sais qu'il en a qui l'ont mal
pris mais je pense que le sait le
contexte c'est toujours pareil le
collins a touché tout le monde pensait
que j'arrive donc c'est vrai dans ce
contexte je l'aï les idées oui
il a même tourné alors il va sur france
2 c'est vrai je te dis qu'il est pas de
comptes qu'il ait pas eu de contrat avec
thé fort en exclure les crises acs est
assez étonnant qu'il ait envie de se
rassurer avec france 2 commence à très
bien c'est vrai que comme les sauf que
d'un contrat il faut qu'il apprenne
chaussée la phrase préférée de taverne
on sait qu'un contrat serait bourré de
tavernot fébrile syrie voilà c'est fait
pour être déchirés donc je comprends son
angoisse mais je trouve que dans le
contexte c'est un petit peu maladroit
mois se commet pas du tout franchement
je suis choqué c'est honteux et je lui
dis à jarret un peu de décence alors le
dessin et ses potes il 17 moi je vous
dis honnêtement il dit j'aurais pu aller
dans la rue mais il ya des gens qui sont
dans la rue il ya des gens qui n'ont
rien il ya des gens qui ont été brisés
par la crise sanitaire il ya des gens
qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas à manger et
lui joue avec ça en disant
ce qu'il a dit c'est en tous les oiseaux
les sols il est dans sa bulle mais
aujourd'hui des fois ça m'a choqué mais
qui ne disent pas que le parisien
inventé parce que le parisien n'avance
pas je suis sûr que ça va être son
excuse suivant que la polémique ne fait
rien je suis dégoûté de ce qu'il a dit
sinon j'ai dit moi je trouve que c'est
une façon s'exprimer comme une autre fo
avait toujours s'arrêter sur les mots
les expressions c'est une expression
c'est une phrase il y l'exil explique
juste qu'il a peur du futur et c'est
tout à son honneur c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui est passé avec qui on voit
ces chariots
jumbo table encombrée vous êtes angoissé
vous moi devriez
vous êtes angoissé nature la vérité moi
je suis parce que c'est vraiment
angoissé parce que je suis arrivé ici au
hasard je vais repartir au hasard chaque
jour que je suis ici j'en profite et je
sais très bien que si un jour ça
s'arrête et ben je retrouve à un travail
dit normal et donc du coup je me dis que
valade et continue on n'est pas mort et
que voilà qui permet à montciel six 6
mois je suis angoissé mois maintenant
puisque je suis en fin de carrière donc
ça m'est égal
commence à peine à décoller mais c'est
vrai quand vous allez quand vous
choisissez dès l'âge de 17 ans 18h10
quitté le foyer enfin la maison vous
devez vous démerder tout de suite j'ai
eu des plaines de job différent j'ai
perdu je me suis retrouvé vraiment dans
des difficultés et c'est donc là
maintenant je suis serein mais il est
vrai que évidemment que j'ai peur du
lendemain évidemment quand on sort d'un
milieu très modeste comme le mien
évidemment c'est ce que c'est que de
galères et donc j'avais plus envie de
connaître la galère alors quand je peux
je comprends et j'ai peur du lendemain
bien sûr il juste c'est vrai que pour
les intermittents pour les comédiens moi
mon père le cowitz à l' angoisse était
vraiment au bout de sa vie c'est bon
c'est vraiment qu'il n'avait plus jamais
à monter sur scène il serait qu'il avait
peur du lendemain dans ce contexte là je
comprends ce qu'il dit mais c'est vrai
que je suis alors je suis pas souvent
d'accord avec verdès il a trop lent mais
c'est vrai que dire je vais entrer dans
la rue
les chiffres
de rien c'est vrai que quand on a
énormément de soucis on peut dépenser
énormément tu ne pas se rendre compte
faire n'importe quoi et s'il parviendra
ce que tu me dis ça part très bien de
laisser leurs pas et pleure pas mais
jamais jamais
mais alors jamais comprends mais ça
c'est quand j'arrivais à faire à sable
mais non chaque comprendre
malheureusement c'est que c'est même pas
une question de revenus qu'on ait mille
dix mille cent mille c'est une question
du quand ça davis pour les gens ça davis
de la même façon mais ça les gens
comprennent pas et on a beau l'expliquer
parce qu'effectivement des sommes qu'on
peut évoquer sont indécentes et je
comprends très bien quand on parle de
centaines de milliers d'euros etc je me
sens que ça choque évidemment que c'est
choquant mais le procédé quand ce
camp-là la pente s'accélère et que vous
déversez qu'on vous dit stop quand vous
coupent tout c'est pareil pour tout le
monde et ça je vous le dis ça vraiment
je le dis c'est pareil pour tout le
monde et on conçoit savez défi c'est
encore plus vrai moi je les vis et moi
j'ai connu ces pannes et c'est pas des
bêtises j'ai connu le moment où vous
êtes la carte bleue vous avez emprunté à
la terre entière tout ce que vous pouvez
emprunter et vous avez les cartes bleues
et il n'y a rien qui sort et vous êtes
vraiment très emmerder alors j'avais un
toit encore avant comprennent la maison
au final mais on
sait que dire de plein de gens donc
merci pas mais c'est pas une situation
pas c'est pas une situation qui
réservait alors elle arrive à tout le
monde elle peut arriver à tout le monde
aussi bien des gens qui gagnent pas
beaucoup d'argent les uns qingwei alors
oui mais oui mais les gens qui gagnent
bien leur vie on va leur dire vous voyez
vous auriez dû faire
48% d'office pour commander oui mais
alors il peut après tu n'es même quand
tu es quand tu paye des impôts mais
le fait même de quoi je parle comme
donné 50% de ce que vous gagnez 5 dvd à
ce que la moitié mais donc il faut faire
alors ça qu'on aimait la moitié de
beaucoup de vacances et la beauté de
goku j'aimais quand c'est la beauté bien
d'énormément c'est il ya des tranches
d'un mois qui a d'énormes aimant ça
reste énormément mais voilà on est
d'accord mais un précédent écho de
beaucoup c'est pas beaucoup
le ghana mais moi c'est un débat sans
fond on ne pourra jamais convaincre les
gens moi
on est tous égaux devant la catastrophe
quand ça davis ça davis pour tout le
monde pareil je vous le dis sincèrement
c'est ça a été écrit expliqué la leur la
cylindrée spirale de l'échec la spirale
de douche à débit soit couteaux des
verts bernard montiel
c'est impossible à expliquer mais c'est
au bout d'un moment quand ça passe plus
ça passe plus c'est pareil pour tout le
monde mais dans cet événement parce
qu'elle ne s'est pas un flambeur et ça
n'a jamais été je suis profondément
profondément choqué du procès que vous
faites à jardiner c'est pas les bras
alors il adore il adore
bien sûr il a raison moi j'ai peur du
lendemain bah oui j'ai toujours eu peur
du lendemain récemment aussi
c'est bon c'est pas pu se marier signé
les accords d'oslo
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est en métal
mais j'ai toujours y paraître c'est
sans rigoler arrête un peu à l'horizon
madeleine beaucoup mais arrête ans j'ai
toujours eu d'isabelle entre je vais pas
reprendre pouvoir reprendre non ça fait
cinquante ans que tu prends rtl est ici
à mes frères et d'art est un peu la
vérité la seule chose que tu achètes
c'est des trucs chez pink qui je te
connais
[Rires]
une augmentation
de la demande est passée pour ça que
vous êtes là n'a plus de temps
pour répondre à jean c'est pas parce
qu'on passe à la télé qu'on est
millionnaire il ya dix ans encore il y
avait ce qu'on appelle des contrats
d'exclusivité que les chaînes avec des
animateurs ou des gens comme jarry en ne
faisant rien ils pouvaient toucher dix
vingt cinquante mille euros par mois là
c'est plus le cas et moi j'ai connu un
animateur sur une très très grande
chaîne qui ne lui donnaient rien et il
avait rien alors c'est bien de passer à
la télé de temps en temps de faire des
gros prague de faire des grosses
émissions et quand vous n'avez rien il
ya un incident sur un animateur qui
n'avaient pas d'exclusivité mais qui
était bloqué par la chaîne et qui avait
rien si on ne fait pas travailler ou que
c'est pas parce qu'on a une image d'un
animateur télé et qu'on pense qu'on est
fortune et c'est qu'en réalité on ne
touche d'argent et des animateurs qui
gagne très peu d'argent et je pense que
j'arrive si les partis c'est que c'est
qu'ils ne s'y retrouver pas voilà non
mais pas si la carrière au sein mais il
a dit qu'il avait versé en fait il a dit
quoi que ce soit mais il avait un
contrat voilà c'est ça et que sur tf1
n'avait pas de contrat mais c'était
voilà ils savaient pas s'ils
seront récurrents
c'était vrai ce qui va capable content
de l'animateur sur france télévisions
exactement à deux producteurs oui pas
d'animateur oui bah alors qu'il avait
tué un co producteur ben c'est de la
fiction non mais c'est possible pour la
non moi je trouve que c'est indécent
fait gilles parce que tu es d'une
démagogie à agir mais d'abord il se
plaint pas oui ils expliquent la
situation et il adore enfin on connaît
pas la vie de jarry non pas avoir des
dettes il peut avoir des emprunts il
peut aider d'une maman il a il est père
de famille ne sais pas et je trouve que
donner des leçons comme ça comme un
petit banquier de dire à mes les
papilles il y gère pas bien mais ils
dépensent trop mais quelle indécence il
dit pas que les qu'il a moins de chance
que les gens ne dis juste que dans sa
situation il est équipé et je trouve
qu'il a droit en fait c'est toujours un
peu moi c'est toujours un peu maladroit
moi je vais dans le sens de gilles parce
que c'est toujours maladroit ce qu'ils
font quand ils font ça il faut il
n'arrive pas à ceux ramenés à ramener
les choses qu'il est qu'il est qui les
fait vivre c'est les gens qui les font
vivre sans les gens sans les gens ils
sont personne c'est pas des métiers
ordinaire c'est moi je dis ici que c'est
pas un métier c'est vrai que c'est une
récré
il va sur scène il a été sur scène
longtemps mais c'est du travail d'aller
paris - vertige et le droit si j'ai le
droit de penser que quand les gens ils
arrivent au boulot le matin on les
applaudit pas on les maquille pas on
leur donne pas des fringues on leur
donne pas décroché le droit de penser
c'est ma pensée j'ai le droit de penser
ça je trouve que là où certains dans
leur camion je trouve que
c'est que c'est pas c'est pas d'hier ça
fait longtemps que j'arrivais sur scène
il a fait des prime sur tf1 ils haïssent
il a acheté une maison pour mieux pour
lui et je vais vous expliquer la
démarche qui me dérange le plus la
démarche qui me dérange le plus c'est
vite fuyons tf1 lui a donné sa chance là
c'est dégueulasse je vais te dire que ça
bah tu vas trouver en corse est belle et
gallas accroche toi tu vas te faisons
plus des
2,6 fait la f1 lui donne sa chance dès
qu'ils voient que le vent il tourne à
bas le coït j'ai fait mon retour n'a là
elle retrouve à la rue comme de tas de
français qui sont vraiment à la rue pour
devrait lui qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
barrett chez tf1 en dix ans et de
quiches et france 2 c'est le pognon des
français qui payent des impôts
il est parti le questionnaire il est
parti comme un mercenaire genna sécurité
chez france télévisions met une
rencontre c'est ce que je vois ça donne
un énorme contrat est mieux que tu avais
escota c'est ce que l'on pense qu'il
partira pas comme un mercenaire pour
pourra le port les audomarois prénom
puisque moi je dis on est le fait de
dire bon j'ai un contrat de chauffeur
livreur j'ai
tout de suite j'ai même pas tiré les
leçons j'ai même pas signé de contrat il
s'est apprécié contre les lyonnais a
tout de suite fait la police fabrice
conca j'ai signé 06 je peux sortir de
nous et on les connaît c'est
à dire et de la
mer ce n'est peut pas lui reprocher
puisque c'est un père de donner d'autres
jetés orientation à sa carrière il a
quoi ces enfants que la famille parce
que sur tf1 je suis bien placé pour le
savoir avec benjamin et bernard si t'as
pas de contrat d'exclusivité si tu ne
fais pas des missions tu n'es pas payé
donc tu n'as rien pas et comme ils
n'avaient pas la scène à côté voilà tout
simplement tu peux pas reprocher aux
gens d'avoir peur de se retrouver lance
jean-françois ça j'en sais ce que ça
fait mal a droit de dire à quelle
formulation soit maladroite sa
formulation maladroite yahia créateur ya
des animateurs qui ont des gros contrats
d'exclus n'a pas je vois il y aurait un
tollé il y en avait deux encore fois que
jean pierre foucault s'est trouvé un
arrangement avec avec tf1 il est encore
sur la chaîne mais de façon différente
oui le dernier qui reste n'a pas encore
je crois que c'est nico serait d'accord
mais c'est quoi nikos et l'animateur qui
gagnent le plus que je vais parce qu'ils
gagnent mais je sais que c'est celui qui
est la situation la plus étalé sur la
chaîne il avait pris et ça se passe très
bien pour lui il avait dit je pense
qu'il a lui-même euros peut-être définir
son contrat qui n'était pas très bon
très bon je crois ou tous des mains
alors à laiteries pour moi mes collègues
qui défendent jarryd moi je vous dis il
a fait il a fait ma singer zhari via le
réseau wi fi gure oui il va être dans
l'émission de la prochaine saison
mais masque singer une prestation de
jury jean dans ma seigneur enfin les
françaises et les français les français
jamais ça valérie descamps tombée de
cheval et le talent est là mais ça ne
croîtra d'exclus mai mais à valérie
c'est un récent sur audition des berges
est déconnecté charge italie non mais
oui mais laissez moi finir j'essaie de
finir bassin
il a touché il a touché des dizaines de
milliers d'euros pour massing alors la
drôme et ses rires vous pouvez pas vous
plaindre après la descente les plans
falaise et lui se plaint les gens qui
avait mené son club
gince pêche peu très peu c'est pas
véronique gênant on lui posait une
question mais en lui demandant pour
quelles raisons vous êtes parti de tf1
france 2 mais voilà le redis je pars de
tf1 prendra parce que j'ai été très ému
avant ils se sont très bien occupé de
moi mais je me sentais en danger parce
que du jour au lendemain je pouvais ne
plus rien avoir hors france 2 me propose
quelque chose où je pense que je pendant
quelques années en tout cas je suis
assuré de prouvant ainsi la voie à sa
mère et je n'ai pas nos je t'aime
beaucoup valais il
je suis en garde les tissus et valérie
je t'aime beaucoup mais vous voulez dans
des métiers de spectacle vous voulez que
ça brille ça change vous voulez que ça à
faire du si vous voulez aller faire des
concerts jeux des concerts c'est une
passion mais tu crois que les gens ils
ont pas des patients mais tous les
matins fois les bouffer sa passion tu
laisse de côté parce qu'il fait mais non
c'est pas démago si le site a peur de te
retrouver sans rien du jour au lendemain
tu vas faire manutentionnaires
un
métier qui brille c'est le risque
regarde y'a des chroniqueurs qui sont
plaints du jour au lendemain c'est le
ris avril oui je serai plus là c'est le
risque a baissé que ça et tu peux pas
sortir une si maladroite même qu'on sort
difficile de dire aux gens j'ai peur de
me retrouver sans rien du jour au
lendemain si tu as peur va chercher un
cdi quelque part va chercher un cd ça
fait 28 ans que janssen est d'accord on
va pas manquer si tu veux venir livrer
tu sera pas sans lendemain et j'aurais
pu mettre connaître
cette phrase là tu la sors à chaque
émission est donc à l'étude est joué
mais c'est quoi le rapport chaque sou
fais que cette jeunesse tous ces
patients et avance que tu connaissais
vie ce qui s'est passé en haute altitude
et non celle qui sévit en carrière
comportement de ceux mais il s'est passé
en iran au nom de quoi tu me dénonce
arrête je dénonce pas jeudi que ses
propos sont
en train de donner son avis en train de
me parler de 1940 et une phrase on sort
une phrase dans deux semaines c'est pas
n'importe quoi c'est juste que vous avez
peur toi la première comptez pas sur la
table pourquoi je suppose
[Applaudissements]
le problème c'est quoi c'est que vous
passez à la télé
j'avais le problème de ça le gamin
devant métier laissez le parler vous
verrez c'est un petit mitron avec ses
éternels moi je pense pas que c'est un
jeu porter je pensais que ces termes et
quand ça s'arrête quand ça s'arrête vous
n'êtes pas contents pourquoi ça s'arrête
parce que c'est un jeu faut prendre ce
que la prendre faut payer vos maisons
fauves ifo qui fait l'album et b faut
pas vous avez vraiment bizarre ça fait
dix ans que tu as tes ppj mots qu'on
calcule les dix ans tpp plus ta carrière
sur rtl mais on va trouver combien
ça fait dix ans ça fait dix ans qu'il
est là il est vrai que quand on fait une
séquence sur cole c'est vrai ça pleure
après dans les loges pourquoi vous
faites ça pourquoi vous me faites ça on
rigole on est là on rigole éléments ont
fait rigoler
et vous verrez pas mais que vous avez
juste raymond fouché rival travail en
cdi à la mairie sera pas viré c'est peut
comprendre que c'est à son elle
attendait mais les voitures et les yeux
juste c'est le résultat de ces maisons
mais tient à faire quand tu travailles
toute la saison alors c'est quoi ton
travail et ses chances d'échapper repas
laser essayer d'être digne de la
confiance que si et comment tu serais
alors et c'est beau et c'est comme cela
merci lisa lehmann justin s'explique je
suis vraiment fait du mépris pour sa
part
cyril y travaillent pas ils jouent au
paddle oui
mais vous en
valise des séquences donc certains
bipèdes ils payent des dizaines et des
dizaines de salaire tous les mois donc
il travaille pas c'est ça
valide les séquences et des emplois moi
j'ai rien les voilà donc lui travaille
pas moi j'ai rien d'autre et un pitre en
fait va vous et crée des objets dont des
vitres enfin des gravures et des
peintures bijoux qui payent des loyers
qui éduquent leurs enfants mais vous
êtes un titre et veulent travailler pas
j'ai jugé le savez comment on appelle
les trois titres
j'ai toujours défendu qui faisait des
français
j'ai toujours dit qu'ils aideraient
et et je t'ai déjà dit c'est parce que
cette discussion on l'a déjà vu plein de
fois sur je peux comprendre que tente ce
que tu veux dire sur on travaille pas
parce que effectivement situe mais si tu
opposes de métier et dont un métier qui
en ce qu'on appelle la pénibilité c'est
à dire des métiers ils sont fatigants
épuisant qui sont à l'usiné et c'est
avec deux lampées sentiment que nous on
travaille pas mais c'est nous mépriser
aussi les noms je ne maîtrise pas je les
adore vraiment j'aime ça arrive ça va
être juste maintenant j'ai un crs juste
d'un humoriste très très connu un des
plus grands c'est pas gad ouais ouais
c'est un cyril pourquoi ton copain
raymond ne veut pas respecter notre
métier alors qu'il veut en être nous
laissant les 6 à 10 mais c'est une
question d'un bâton humoriste dit lui
déjà d'une que j'ai pas envie de
remonter sur scène j'ai pas envie d'être
humoriste moi je viens là c'est une
récré tu me dis de venir pour donner mon
avis sur l'actuelle jeu là des gens qui
lisent très insultant ou et même les
acteurs ou les intermittences avec les
retours mais surtout la f1 quand tu
vieillis par le public unique robin mais
ça s'est passé pas devant tout le monde
sauf
celle avec le public qu'on ait pu
jusqu'à présent maintenant prêtre est
montré qu'aucun ne se ferait pas sans
les avis que c'est un match c'est sûr
mais c'est un métier extraordinaire
c'est un métier qui pour un métier tu
prend de l'argent vite rapidement et je
suis bien placé pour savoir je parle de
ce que j'ai mais c'est pas un métier
alors allez-y démagogie à daisy c'est un
métier les magots alesi et bien écoutez
bien c'est pas un métier où tu par un 6
heures demain et demie du matin et tu
rentres à 19 heures le temps sont 1400
bat 4 as que je ne sais pas ce que je
viens de citer alors mais non à l'oas
quand tu écris un spectacle sais pas si
tu fais un film
c'est mal payés vous me ferez pas si les
deux légendes du jeu mais presque c'est
pour moi tu restes mais le prij tour
parce que c'est méchant ce que tu sais
ce que je pense les gens ils travaillent
et jarryd du plaisir aux gens il a fait
une série qui a cartonné j'ai jamais dit
j'ai jamais dit le contraire mais si
c'est maintenant on est déjà mariées
contredire concède jean tendance au real
j'ai failli me retrouver à la rue j'ai
peur j'espère juste qu'ils ont pas l'âme
en garder que dans un rôle j'arrive je
n'aurais pas qu'ils soient jarry
contourner
vous êtes opposés alors que vous je ne
sais pas comment expliquer que c'est
magique ce qu'est ce qui vous arrive
comme métier c'est magique mais tu as
mangé en 2001 john ans que je vis de
nommer deux horaires et de dire ça c'est
magique qui ont été envoyés à l'époque
déjà avec camille combal qui étaient
déjà là tu vas déjà de la télé arrête
wallemme de dire énorme et n'a rien fait
des coupes seniors g dredge de même plus
loin fait avec l'an 2010 et avec cyril
en 2010 avec ménages depuis plus
longtemps que moi mais non
bon allez je parle mais si vous voulez
alesi si vous voulez mais
quels étaient les enfants non c'est pas
que c'est mais présente et il parle il
parle de lui tout le monde se comprend
réellement dans ce débat là raymond moi
ce que je te reproche et sincèrement
avec le car ce que je te reproche c'est
que tu as fait un choix de vie temps à
regarder ton travail et tu peux aussi
concilier les deux c'est à dire que tu
fais les deux tu fais ton travail et tu
dis que tu viens à la police et tué deux
et tout bien faire le clown ici on
demande qu'on a vite et comptant au
filet malgré son content de venir
prendre pour nos oreilles j'te primes
prendront de zain et toi t'as se tasser
alors moi je veux dire tu structuré où
il n'a jamais voulu arrêter son vrai
travail c'est pour ça que le maire
tenait bien son vrai nom mais non mais
ça
prouvait à qui prend cette épreuve ici
il prend son rôle ici comme un loisir
merci oui l'a jamais à rien sans rien il
aurait plus un moment il vient il ya
tout le temps et c'est très bien que je
ne lâcherai pas mais voilà mais il a
jamais vous les civils on peut arrêter
de poser deux soleils les vrais ou faux
travail non mais passé je comprends
qu'il ya des taux lui son premier
travail le boulot qu'ils sont d'une
pénibilité absolue il ya des gens qui
sont malheureusement c'est un luxe qu'on
à nous de faire le métier de nos rêves
mois gamine j'avais 13 ans je voulais
faire journalistes c'était mon métier
c'était mon rêve regardez bernard auquel
il voulait rien faire
c'est mon rêve malheureusement ce n'est
pas le cas de tout le monde mais pas
pour autant que parce que j'ai réussi à
rester mon rêve ce que je suis en train
de faire et parle pas du tout comme
j'aime sincèrement c'est que tu juges
les gens en fait je suis un jugement
parce que toi ta vie elle est comme ça
donc tout le monde devrait voir la vie
de la même manière je pense qu'il faut
que tu restes tu sais pas un martyr est
donc un artiste je suis cliente des
artistes il ya des chanteurs il ya des
acteurs il ya des intermittents du
spectacle il ya plein de gens m'ont dit
artiste et plein de gens et en fait il
ya des artistes qui s'y met à fond tu
sais pas quel harris réveil mais il va
qui travaillent énormément il y avait
des quatre
essais
travail a condamné ces les gens vivent
pas
merdé pas merci mais j'attends mais
véronique genest qui s'efforcent invité
je pouvais pas venir je vous dis quoi
c'est un projet assez bon